باريس مدينه الانوار والاناقه وقصص العشاق
مغطاه بالقمامه التي تغطي ربما القليل من
النور في عاصمه النور نحو نصف احياء
العاصمه الفرنسيه متكدسه بالنفايات بسبب
تواصل احتجاجات عمال جمع القمامه
الاضرابات بدات منذ الاسبوع الماضي
اعتراضا على خطه الحكومه لرفع سن التقاعد
من سن 57 الى 59 عاما يطالب جامعون نفايات
ايضا زياده الاجور حتى يحصل على معاش
تقاعدي اعلى قليلا الاضراب خلف نحو 7000
طنا من اكياس القمامه على ارصفه المدينه
ومن الممكن ان يستمر حتى يوم الاثنين
المقبل على الاقل في المقابله القمامه
المنتشره تقدم وجبات مجانيه لا نهائيه
لجرذان المدينه البالغ عددهم نحو سته
ملايين فار هذا النوع من الاضرابات ليس
بالجديد على تاريخ المدينه الفرنسيه مزيد
حول ابرز ما شهدته في العوامل الماضيه مع
زميل تنا لميس ابراهيم
خلال السنوات الماضيه شهدت العاصمه باريس
وعدد من المدن الفرنسيه اضرابات عمال جمع
القمامه احتجاجا على قرارات حكوميه مختلفه
في اكتوبر عام 2010 ادى اضراب جميع
القمامه الذي استمر لثلاثه اسابيع على
الاقل الى تراكم النفايات حول ميناء
مارسيليا وكان ذلك بسبب اعلان الحكومه رفع
سن التقاعد الى 62 عاما بدلا من 60
بعدها بخمس سنوات اضرب اكثر من 45% من
عمال جمع القمامه في باريس عن العمل بحجه
ان الاجور زهيده ولا تتماشى مع تكاليف
المعيشه وقبل ايام من صافره انطلاق بطوله
اليورو في فرنسا في يونيو 2016 بدا اضراب
عمال جمع القمامه بسبب خطه لتخفيف قوانين
العمل ومنح الشركات مساحه اكبر لاتخاذ
المزيد من القرارات بشان التوظيف او الفصل
وتحديد الاجور وفي يناير 2020
وبسبب قانون رفع سن التقاعد الذي يعتزم
البرلمان التصويت بشانه حاليا فاضت
القمامه من صناديق النفايات بعدما اضرب
العمال عن العمل في سته من اصل سبع محارق
نفايات
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو نورنا اليوم وراسل العربيه
في باريس حسين القنيبر حسين يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك من جديد معنا في الاستوديو صباح
الخير صباح الخير كيفكم طيب حسين النفايات
تغزو للاسف مدينه الانوار 7000 طن من
النفايات ملقاه في الشوارع ولا كيف بدات
الازمه
يعني في الواقع هناك اولا النوع من
المبالغه في تصوير ما يحصل
ولكن يعني طبعا الازمه بدات لان عمال
النفايات قرروا الشروع في اضراب من ضمن
حركه الاضرابات التي تشهدها عده قطاعات في
باريس احتجاجا كما تعلمان على رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
الجديد خلينا نكسر شوي الجديه الاخباريه
ونحكي باللهجه العاميه وشكرا لصباح
العربيه لانها تتيح هالفرصه هايدي
الجديد انه عمال النفايات قرروا تمديد
الاضراب لعشرين الشهر على الاقل مثل ما
قالوا يعني في احتمال انه تتمدد لاكثر من
هيك بس سهامنا الدين بدي اتهمكم بمحاوله
تشويه صوره باريس والعتب عليكم كبير لانه
انتم كمان فرانكفون
في لغه فرنسيه بس
اسال السؤال اللي كنت بدي اساله هلا
احرجته اكثر من هيك زميلنا وسام فيروز
اللي عم يعمل جهد كبير بهالبرنامج وتحيه
له هو مش بس فرانكو فون هو فرانكو فيل
يعني عنده عنده هوى للثقافه الفرنسيه يهوى
فرنسا وثقافه في نوع من المبالغه صحيح في
قمامه وصلت الى مستوى ال 7000 منتشره في
شوارع باريس هيدا له تداعيات جماليه يشوه
المشهد السياحي تداعيات الصحيه بيعمل
امراض بكتيريه وله تداعيات اقتصاديه عدد
كبير من المطاعم المؤسسات عم يشكوا من انه
بعض الزبائن ما عادوا يفوتوا على مطاعم
على مدخل عدد كبير من حاويات النفايات
واحيانا اكياس من دون حاويات حسين قبل
ازمه حياه
اصطلح دائما بيقولوا مثلا متلازمه باريس
باريس ساندروم او بالفرنسي سندباغي كيف
ترد على من يطرح هذه الفكره
لتصوير هذه المدينه يعني المدينه من اشهر
الوجهات السياحيه في العالم ومدينه الموضه
وثقافه الاكل فيها بان تتحول الى متلازمه
لدى البعض
لا هو بالواقع يعني ما تشهده باريس
تشهده كل العواصم التي تشهد اضرابات
واحتجاجات لانه هذه المساله صارت وسيله
ضغط تمارسها بلديه باريس تحديدا التي
تتراسها اشتراكيه هي
المتضامنه مع المضربين وتعتبر انه على
الحكومه ان تتراجع عن قرار رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما ولكن البلديه بتقول طبعا انه
نحن عم نعمل كل شيء لوضع النفايات في
حاويات مش في اكياس تجنبا للامراض اذا
التفسير هو انه ما يحصل في باريس يمكن ان
يحصل في اي عاصمه اخرى بس لفتني طبعا
العنوان اللي حطيته انه نور اقل
وقمامه اكثر صحيح هذا الحكي ده نتيجه ازمه
الطاقه في بعض الشوارع بباريس باتت تشهد
اطفاء عند الاضواء ليلا لتوفير الطاقه فهو
محزن اللي عم يحصل ولكن هو بالسياق
العالمي الذي يشهد متغيرات ما كنا
لنتخيلها قبل سنوات تحديدا حسين رفع سن
التقاعد موضوع حساس جدا الفرنسيين لماذا
تقود حكومه ماكرون هذا المشروع
لانه هي بتعتبر انه ارتفاع المعدل الوسطي
لاعمار الفرنسيين نتيجه التقدم الطبي
الناس وسطيا كانت تعيش 78 سنه للرجال
كمعدل وسطي و85 للنساء هذا كل ما هو عم
يرتفع وتمويل الرواتب التقاعديه لكل
هالاعداد مع ارتفاع الاعمار فرض عجز على
ميزانيه التقاعد ستصل الى 20 مليار يورو
سنه 2030 هذا لا يمكن تمويله هالعجز او سد
هالعجز الا من خلال فرض سنتين اضافيتين من
العمل على الفرنسيين والى الازمه التي
تتزامن معها تمديد اضراب العمال النفايات
تزداد في التكدس اليوم حسين اكيد ما حدا
بيحب يسمع عن عاصمه النور هذه السمعه بس
انت بتعيش فيها لسنوات وكونت كمان اسره
جميله جدا في باريس هل باعتقادك انه هي
ازمه وستزول سريعا ستنت هي ام انها ستطول
لا في الواقع الامر يعني عم جرب انا ابعد
عن السياسي من الموضوع بس مضطرين نحكي
كلمتين عن السياسي بدي افتح بس براكتس
لاقول انه انتم عم تاخدوا اللي عم بيصير
بباريس كذا ذريعه سهام وندين حتى لا تاتيا
الى باريس ونحن موعودين فيكم من زمان برجع
بحكي اذا كانت ستطول او لا اليوم ستحسب
الامور اليوم سيصار الى التصويت بالجمعيه
الوطنيه اي مجلس النواب على النسخه
الجديده لنص مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد اللي صار فيه توافق عليها من ضمن
اللجنه برلمانيه مختلطه بتتكون من 14
برلماني اذا مر بمجلس النواب هذا المشروع
القانون بتكون صعب على النقابات تستمر
بحركه الاحتجاجات اذا لم يمر واضطرت
الحكومه لاستخدام البنك 49 الماده ثلاثه
التي تتيح لها تمرير اي مشروع قانون حتى
لو لم يوافق عليه البرلمانيون ستنزل
النقابات بقوه الى الشارع وستشهد الحركه
الاجتماعيه تصاعدا لو تيره الاضرابات
والتظاهرات اليوم بنشوف ومنخبركم اذا مشي
الحال ما بيكون عندكم
حسين اهلي بفرنسا يعني مع نفايات من دون
نفايات انا جايه جايه واحنا اهل واحسن
اهلنا كمان جايين
لعندنا نادين شكرا
جزيلا الله يخليك